Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burden.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast in
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
Um,
I'll be back in la baby.
Came back to see my family at my daughter in there.
Um,
greatest fucking day of my life.
So excited.
Um,
packet with the family,
hanging out,
having an awesome time and uh,
it's all I did.
That's all I did all day.
Just hung out with the Kiddo,
my lovely wife and uh,
everything's good.
Dealt with the stack of mail,
you know,
as you do,
you come back to all the bills.
Keep coming.
Don't they write 20,
40,
6,800.
Get the fuck out of here.
What do you want?
Four or 500 bucks?
Fucking pastors.
They just won't let you just,
I don't understand.
I don't get how you retire.
It's like you have to become like,
you got to become like this feudal fucking landowner will.
You've got a bunch of people with tuberculosis living in some shit hole that you
fucking own.
That's the only way to not end this ride,
eat and fucking owl Paul,
you know,
waiting for a bus.
I don't know how you do it.
They just won't let you sit fucking still,
you know?
Say what you want about the caveman days.
How the only lived to be like 26 and he looked like they were 105 is fucking
people could chill out.
Go out.
You kill a fucking woolly mammoth.
I mean,
yeah,
you gotta be good for a while,
right?
Just fucking laying around.
This is amazing.
I guess.
Then you've got to fight off other shit that tries to kill it.
Just say,
you know,
once you fucking,
yeah,
you kill some.
You brought it back.
Lace.
Let's go.
Let's get a fire going sweetheart.
You just fucking sat around.
Your little fucking furry me on bees.
Made out of some platypus.
I don't know yet.
I'm telling you man,
the devil runs the fucking planet.
The whole thing.
Just fucking,
the whole thing is set up on somebody above you.
Make some money off of you.
Right?
And if there's no one below you
that you're making money off of 10 your fucking eating dog food.
That's how it goes.
It's just fucking,
it's unbelief.
It just fucking,
I told you guys,
I saw this guy,
I've number of times I've just seen homeless people just,
I saw this guy just sitting in the sun,
right?
Burning up.
Even then he was just sit there submittal the afternoon,
just one of these restaurants that has tables out on the sidewalk and shit and
they didn't really know.
They're not policing them.
There's nobody there.
So he's just sitting there sleeping sun on his face and he's got a fucking cold,
45 empty quarter left.
I don't know what.
And I'm walking down the street fucking sitting there and thinking about all
this shit I gotta handle.
That's what I made in Atlanta and I just looked at that guy.
No,
it's just like,
you know what,
that,
that doesn't look that bad
obviously.
You know,
day in and day out.
It sucks.
But you know how they have like Earth Day,
the honor just have like,
just like a homeless day.
It's just something where it's just okay to be in public,
taken a nap,
shit faced in the middle of the day.
Why everybody else goes to work like you,
you get it.
It's like getting called for jury duty,
except it's fun.
Hey boss,
I'm not going to be in to work on Tuesday off.
Fuck.
We need your I,
I,
I got a homeless day.
I ain't fair enough.
Fair enough.
And then you just go out,
you grab your fucking drink at choice,
you'll find a bench and he just get fucking hammered.
You just fight one in the afternoon.
You're asleep.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Maybe this is because I've been on the wagon here for fucking nine weeks then
I'm looking at stuff like that.
But,
um,
I dunno.
I have no idea.
So I flew back,
took the first flight back.
I can't wait to tell you guys about this fucking movie.
Uh,
I've got to do a scene with one of my favorite actors of all freaking time and
one of my favorite people and I was having such a good time.
I didn't even get a goddamn picture with them.
Um,
which is always fucking,
he can't,
he can't really do that.
But I know that I already knew this guy before,
uh,
before I did it.
Um,
but we should've,
we should've got a fucking picture.
But anyways,
um,
so on the flight back,
I watched a cool hand,
Luke,
one of my favorite movies of all time and fast times at Ridgemont high.
Uh,
it was just both movies totally held up.
And,
uh,
one of the greatest fucking lines that has never quoted in fast times at
Ridgemont high,
his Dimone,
when he knocks up Jennifer,
Jason Leigh,
and once he,
he goes,
you know,
is it mine?
And he goes,
get shores.
He goes,
you know,
I suppose you want me to pay for it?
Oh my God,
what a fucking line.
I suppose you want me to pay for it?
It's like,
buddy,
she's fucking given you a do over.
You just fucked your whole life up.
You fucked her life up.
She's given you a fucking do over.
If he can live with it,
if you could fucking live with it.
You know what I mean?
I,
you know something,
I can't even talk about that talk cause I don't even know where the hell I stand
on that thing.
Um,
I don't even know where I stand,
but like when people say it's to take it a little of a life,
I'm like,
yeah,
it is.
It is it,
my argument is if you didn't have that procedure there,
there would be a person
somewhere along the line somebody got whacked because there's one less person.
Yeah.
That's all I'm saying.
I don't know who the Hitman is.
You know,
you're sort of the dawn,
you know,
if you have the procedure done,
you say gotta you gotta fucking take this guy out.
And then somebody,
then the doctor goes in and he's like the fucking,
he's that dude in the white suit in the untouchables.
Really built,
you're going to fucking joke about abortion.
I don't know.
I don't plan these things.
I just start talking,
you know,
and I got some fucking 20 make fucking cunt face giving me shit that I got too
much sports,
dribble on it,
dribble on this thing.
Rarely dribble like the fucking shit coming out of the side of your mouth when
you sit there watching the Guy Damn Kardashians.
Is that what you want me to talk about?
Oh,
did you see what Miss New York said?
The flavor flavor?
I don't give a fuck.
Ah,
but you know,
if you're into it,
that's,
you know,
that's your thing.
Do your thing.
It's your fate.
What she want to watch.
I can't tell you.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so I watch cool hand Luke and uh,
I haven't seen that in a minute.
I forgot how creepy.
Uh,
what's his face?
Oh my God.
He just fucking flaked on his name.
Kennedy,
George Kennedy,
that his fucking name.
Oh,
Jesus.
But I gotta look it up now.
George Kennedy,
he is,
and he's a big mother fucker and he had a pot belly and he lived to be like 91
years old.
That doesn't happen.
Those big guys,
you know,
they slap people around for six decades and then all of a sudden they just face
down in a newspaper.
Mike,
are you okay?
Um,
hang on a second.
Uh,
is it George Kennedy?
Yeah,
that's it.
George Kennedy,
when he's,
when he,
when you know the girl who washes the fucking car,
he keeps calling.
Oh Lucy or name scattered the Lou.
She,
I got to watch it again to try to get his accent down.
She was older.
They're
often at Carl.
All your pinhole in it.
Hold it together.
I didn't understand like they couldn't like,
like back then they couldn't talk about like prison rape and shit.
So they just had these guys sitting in there like reading like dirty fucking
stories about like red shoe diaries,
shit to each other and then what?
They get all fucking frustrated.
I mean at that point somebody is going to fuck something or beat the shit out of
somebody,
but it never does.
Um,
but anyways,
what a fucking great,
what a God damn.
Great movie.
I fucking love that movie.
Yeah.
Well I love how that's his fucking attitude.
Well,
you know,
his mother comes to fucking visit him,
basically says,
yeah,
I'm going to die while you're in here.
I'll see you later.
Cackling and fucking hacking up a lung.
Um,
I love that movie.
And you know what I love about cool hand Luke,
he's like a fucking,
you know what I mean?
Fucking hates authority.
You tell them to go left,
he's going to go fucking right eat taking him.
Obviously he's doing this at a prison level.
I don't,
I don't recommend that.
But there's all,
there's a through,
like when I watched that guys like this fucking,
this is like the kind of guy in high school that you'd hang out with.
Like people,
there's been a problem with,
with people driving their car,
students driving their cars too fast.
I don't know who's driving on the property.
And then the second you fucking say that,
that's it.
He's going to take his car and that weekend he's going to do fucking donuts.
Laughing his balls off.
Just knowing that it's going to irritate somebody.
I don't know,
maybe I'm missing the point of the movie,
but um,
yeah,
just a fucking great movie.
Do you know,
uh,
actually one of the,
when they go to pave the road,
they're throwing the sand on top of whatever the fuck they're spraying on the
road.
Um,
that music was composed for that scene.
And then somebody connected with the movie,
sold it to the nightly news and that became the nightly news song.
And uh,
some of the actors were upset because they felt it ruined that scene.
Uh,
you don't hear it now,
but that was the song that they played for like decades.
Uh,
whatever the fuck that was.
I think I've actually already talked about this on the podcast.
Um,
anyways,
what do you want from me?
All right.
Onto my sports drivel.
Um,
what enough fuck is going on with these fucking New York Yankees Day or Goddamn
buzzsaw.
This is the second series in a row where they play rope a dope.
They lean on the ropes,
they let you win game one.
Oh good.
We won game one.
Who Fuck it,
hold it home court here,
holding home serve whatever they say.
And then they win game two.
And then you think you got them.
Okay.
You're thinking to yourself,
these fucking morons.
Now they gotta win four out of five or they got to win the next three in a row.
Why do they do the Yankees right now are given the epitome.
If you look up right there,
Fred,
in the fucking dictionary,
that's what they're doing.
That's what they're doing.
And what the fucking Indians and astro is.
That dawn is a classic example of cold lotion.
What they're doing to their fence or what the Indians did,
they won the first two.
They got 'em all fucking excited.
Whether you went 22 fucking games in a row and then you lose three in a row.
I have to be up to two to two zip in a five game series.
Um,
anyways,
the fucking Dodgers are up three games to none out here.
You'd never know.
You know what I realized with the Dodgers being up three games to none,
one game away from the world series and I don't,
I didn't even fucking know about it.
You know what it is.
I don't have enough Mexican friends out here because those people,
God bless them,
are single handedly keeping that franchise here in La.
I swear to God,
if they were going to the games,
that fucking team would have left somewhere.
I don't know when the 80s.
Yeah,
I don't know what it is.
I know there's,
I don't,
I don't want to know where the white guy fucking grew up here in la baseball fan
lives.
I just don't know where the fuck they are.
I haven't seen,
they were up three games to none.
I didn't see,
I drove from lax all the way to my house.
I didn't see one banner.
I didn't fucking feel any buzz.
Nobody with the hat.
Nobody with a Jersey Zip,
nothing.
Um,
I was stunned when I,
I mean,
I've been working so I wasn't paying attention.
I thought,
I thought it was like two one,
somebody I didn't know it was three games to none.
I didn't know they are right on the fucking break.
MMM.
Do you realize,
okay,
if the fucking Yankees win and the Dodgers win and we have a Yankees dodger
fucking series,
okay.
They're going to do the whole
Brooklyn Dodgers.
I got the name dad years.
They were the trolley Dodgers and blah,
blah,
Blah and Ebbets field.
And somehow somewhere,
some fucking old bastard is going to come out of the woodwork and start talking
about it,
right.
You know,
fuck all of that.
All right,
not fuck all of that baseball is,
is,
is as,
as sport steeped in history,
as long as they bring up Vince Scully,
it's going to be fucking great.
But all I'm saying is that takes me back to when I first started watching
baseball,
1977 1978 back to back fucking years.
I rooted for the Dodgers because the red sox could not beat the fucking Yankees.
And then we,
you know,
and that was the Bucky Dent Year was 78 and I would root for them
and they lost 77 to Dodgers and I rooted for them again and they lost again.
Then the next year was pirates first the orals orals up three games to one gave
their fans the old cold lotion.
Pirates came back with the right there,
Fred one at seven.
Then you had 1980 was a Pete rose.
Ah,
let me get 50 on your fucking page.
Boy Haircut.
He gig goes over to the Phillies.
Right.
I quit the fuck.
Did they play in the world series?
I think it was Kansas City.
They finally got past the Yankees.
That's what it was.
Um,
yeah.
Every year I root for Kansas City,
then they'd lose and then a root for the Dodgers.
But Kansas City got passed and then Pete Rose fucking led the Phillies to their
first world series victory in a hundred fucking years.
They won one in like 1881 or some shit.
And then 1980 they were actually the cubs before the fucking cubs.
Just everybody forgets.
Um,
then 1981,
the Dodgers play the Yankees again and I'm like,
what the fuck?
You know,
third time's got to be a chairman.
They finally fucking one.
I believe that was with Fernando Valens Waylon,
wasn't it?
Dave winfield and Port Tommy.
John played for the Dodgers and 77 loss to the Yankees.
Played for the Dodgers and 78 lost to the Yankees and 81.
Hey,
switch tapes.
Eight plays for the New York Yankees and he loses to the fucking Dodgers.
Yeah.
Oh,
Jesus.
Can you imagine how quiet that fucking ride was home with his,
with his wife?
My goodness,
Tommy.
At least they named a surgery after you.
MMM.
Anyways,
by the way,
I know there's everybody's fucking,
I don't know,
talking about this horrific injury.
MMM.
I gotta make sure I get his name right.
He's brand new.
He said,
Hayward,
that poor fucking guy
a,
I'm going to write Haywood is that guy on the white shadow,
Hayward Gordon Hayward.
You know,
here's the thing.
Everybody's freaking out about it.
Like,
oh my God.
I was like,
yeah,
it was fucking grotesque.
But,
uh,
if I was him,
I would be psyched that it was a bone and not blowing out your Achilles or your
fucking ACL.
Because according to this guy I talked to in a bar one time,
who is not a physician on any fucking level,
he,
uh,
I don't know,
maybe we of these sports center things,
I don't know what he's,
I overheard at some point that when you break a bone,
if it's set right,
when it grows back,
it's actually strong.
So he's going to come back with a bionic ankle and tendons.
Fine.
I think it will be backed by a,
I'm going to say is a non doctor and not looking at the xrays that I don't know
how to read.
I'm going to say in February,
I say it comes back in February.
MMM.
It'll be fine.
It's just,
it's just that his fist fucking,
yeah,
the angle that his foot was that um,
that was brutal.
But I'll tell you,
it's still not as bad as Joe Theismann.
It's not as bad as Joe Theismann.
It's not as bad as far as grotesque.
That fucking kid was at Louisville a few years ago with the kids just ran away
when that happened.
Um,
I still haven't looked at that one.
And then there was a time I saw in the UFC,
this guy fucking kick somebody compound fracture and he brought his leg back to
put weight on it and he didn't realize he had broken both bones down there.
What's,
what's,
what's below your knee,
what is that?
That,
that the radius and the Ulna.
That's your fucking arm.
Then you got the humerus and you get your femur.
You got your Patella,
you get your tarsals,
you metal tarsals and your flange is,
what the fuck is down there?
Your Fibula and your tibular.
Oh,
frick and frack it.
A leg there,
right?
The twins,
the twins fucking hanging around like the little fish in the,
you're famous,
the whale there,
they're a little fishies underneath it.
Right?
He fucking broke both of those things and he goes to put all his weight on the
Goddamn leg and his,
you ever see a little kid put on adults like rain boot on that goes up to their
knee and then it just kind of fold.
That's what the fuck happened.
Ah,
yeah,
that was a gross.
Well,
let's talk about the broken leg.
Obviously Joe Theismann is sort of the,
um,
one small step for man,
one giant leap for mankind.
That's like the fucking lunar landing of broken bones on,
in sports.
That's,
that's sort of the original as far as I remember.
And then there was,
of course,
the,
uh,
the guy walked in,
I never know the fighters names.
The guy fucking walked in.
He'd come walking in like a crab or a spider and he's fucking around that one
fight,
acting like he wasn't hurting than the guy fucking really knocked him out.
Then he was like,
all right,
I'm coming back.
And he went to go kick him and he fucking broke both bones.
That was fucking brutal.
And I,
I left the room.
I was like,
I don't want to see that again.
And My,
my wife rewound that like fucking,
I don't know how many times was fascinated by fascinate.
It's unbelievable.
I can't fart in bed,
but she can fucking sit there and look at that.
I mean,
I mean women try to figure them out.
Um,
anyways,
whatever.
Was it 19 minutes in Jesus,
Chris,
tell me more.
Fuck that.
I get it.
I don't have my advertising with me.
I'm just going to plow through this.
Um,
oh man,
I got to a nice political debate up here.
I'll tell you,
you know,
this is what you gotta do.
You pray if you're in a red state right now or if you're in a blue state,
you're probably sick of people that agreed with you.
So what you need to do is you need to go to another state and just wait til
politics comes up and you just argue the other side.
You have a great fucking time.
You know,
like when I'm in a red state,
if I say anything about Trump or whatever,
like people,
the heads almost explode.
Okay?
Like it,
she tells me fucking Hillary with a fucking,
you know,
they do that.
And then out here and see exact opposite.
Um,
this person I was arguing with today just kept grabbing their head
like they,
they couldn't believe
they were talking about like,
that Hillary didn't win because she was a woman.
And I was just like,
I was basically saying that there was probably some sexism obviously.
Right.
But like it's just,
it's not just one fucking thing.
There's a whole bunch of things.
There's also the fact that people are sick of the Clintons and the sick of the
bushes,
the bushes in the,
I want Jeb Bush came along.
It's like how many times did he bang Barbara [inaudible] how many are there
after awhile?
Like a political family just gets played out and you just don't want it.
You just don't want to see him get you want the bushes and the Clintons are
right now.
Do you remember whether they would like in the 10th season of the office and
even Steve Carell was like,
dude,
this is over.
He like fucking left and they just can't make it more of a,
that's what the Clintons and fucking bushes are.
It's just it,
it's over.
It's over.
Okay.
Gets your residuals and ride off into the sunset.
They just won't do it.
They keep coming back for another season.
Um,
yeah,
so it's unbelievable.
So if you bring up anything that Trump does to Trump people,
they lose their fucking minds.
If you bring up anything that like,
like all these sees what the other person fucking did,
it's unreal.
That would be like me as a sports fan,
not being able to see like how amazing it is,
what the Yankees are doing right now.
I'm not saying like,
you know,
I can't say I'm rooting against him.
I gotta be honest with you.
It's a fucking red sox fan.
49 years old.
The for me,
the movie was all for me.
Did I just say I said that for real,
for real.
Z for realsy.
I just feel like for me,
2004,
that was it.
That was the end of the movie roll credits.
You know it's fucking over.
You can't shit 1918 at us anymore.
No matter how much you say we choked,
we'll never going to choke more than you guys did.
There was a historical fucking choke.
No one's ever done that.
Noah ever do that again with a $200 million fucking team.
No one will ever be first again.
You know what I mean?
There'll be the Kobe,
they won't be the Jordan of choking.
Um,
there'll be the second one doing what had already been done.
So I'll be,
that was the end roll credits.
It's over.
And then we want to more so who gives a shit?
What do we were going to catch the Yankees,
this 30 fucking teams now that you can't then all of those sports,
you can't,
you know,
unless she got two teams going at it,
like Celtics and Lakers.
Um,
although the Lakers caught up with the Celtics as even as all these teams
increased.
So I fucking hate saying that as a Celtics fan.
But what they've done,
I feel is the most amazing.
They won the most championships in my fucking lifetime since 1968.
I fucking hate saying that,
but it's true.
These fucking bastards,
they could build a team.
And then when it went into the free agent thing,
they had all these fucking whores out here,
all these starlets for these fucking guys to bang.
And they had the great weather and we just couldn't keep up with them.
We couldn't keep up with them.
We had fucking winter,
you know,
we,
uh,
you know,
we had racist racism and shit.
They got racism out here to Jesus Christ.
You know,
it's the racisms fucking equal.
But you know,
so then the tipping point becomes the weather in the Hollywood fucking who was,
I mean right there.
It's over.
It's fucking over.
We've got palm trees and Hollywood fucking who was all right.
What do we get?
What do we got?
We got the freedom trail and a Sam Adams beer.
I mean this,
you know,
I mean,
come on,
you're just not going to some,
you might want to get one of those big goofy European guys to fall for that
shit,
but you're not going to get an American.
Um,
anyways,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about here.
Uh,
I will say that this is,
this is the fucking thing.
Houston astro fence.
Uh,
I'm apologizing now cause I love your uniforms.
Reminds me of the fucking orange crushes back when they put the real fucking
sugar in them.
Uh,
uniforms.
Who great till you hit a rough three games.
Okay.
Um,
did you guys notice?
All right,
I was joking with this comic,
Yannis Pappas,
right?
I was joking with them how,
you know,
he's going,
Houston's a strong team at home.
And I was like,
all right,
but like the Yankees fan base,
like
okay,
the sound of the crowd is this.
They used to winning and there's an expectation even though that you know,
I mean a drought for them as they haven't won since 2009 okay.
There's an expectation and there's an n the they have a level that's
unacceptable.
Okay.
And there's very few crowds.
You hear that in a Celtic crowd.
You hear that in a Yankee crowd.
I hate to say that she hear that with Montreal Canadian,
but they're hanging on by the fucking
skinny their teeth.
Cause it's been so fucking long that they at this point have two generations
that have never seen a fucking Stanley Cup.
So what you need,
you need that continued fucking success to get that train fucking rolling.
All right.
Houston astro crowd.
Yeah,
I mean you guys sound like you guys are one of those towns where it's a playoff
game and it's in your big fucking deal is you're going to,
everybody's going to show up and where the same colored free tee shirt,
you know what I mean?
Somebody's going,
are you
rolling?
Right.
Doing that dumb shit.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno if you need to win a bunch of championships to get that fucking sound.
But uh,
I don't know,
but you don't hear it that often.
And when I listened to the Yankees in October,
the Celtics and fucking Megan in June,
I'm the old forum had that sound.
I think,
you know,
if,
if you sit in the upper deck at Staples Center,
I think you'd probably hear it,
but like a staples centers I've said for a long time,
one of the most hostile fucking venues there is,
it's just if you've got money you down below and if you don't,
you're up top go fuck yourself in the moat.
Inbetween is just three stories of luxury boxes.
I mean,
I dunno if you've ever gone to a third world country where there's like 10% of
the people have,
have like fucking all the money and then everybody else has a 10 fucking shack.
The staple center.
That's the way it's set up.
Um,
anyways,
so who knows?
I'm going to watch that game six if I'm not working.
I don't know when the fuck it is.
I think Friday,
uh,
work.
I'm in Austin.
Oh,
that's right.
I'm in Austin,
Texas this weekend.
I got two shows Friday both sold out.
Thank you very much.
And then I got one on Saturday and I,
you know what I decided because my,
my Madison square garden recording ain't happening.
I don't know what to do with it.
It's a,
I fucked up.
I thought when I said,
told him that I wanted to record,
that they understood that I was making an album and they just took it right from
the board.
So I sound all loud and happy.
Like I'm killing it.
Madison Square Garden.
And then the crowd sounds like it's a coffee house.
So the recording sounds ridiculous.
Like why is this guy so excited?
You know,
he's not doing that well.
Um,
so I've decided when I go to the cool venues like this Austin city limits,
I'm just going to start recording my shit and I don't know what I'm going to do
with it.
I think I'm just going to randomly put out some vinyls,
like some vinyl albums and,
um,
whatever.
Just to fucking have him.
Who knows?
Someday I'm fucking dead and gone.
There'll be these different versions of my hour of bullshit then I was working
on.
Right.
That'd be interesting.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I don't know if that works with jokes.
Uh,
so when he was,
I'm going to be recording this weekend,
so,
uh,
I don't know if that's an added fucking little
cheese.
It,
that'll get you to come down there.
I have no idea.
I'm working with fucking Dean del Rey and then we're hanging around on fucking
Sunday and we'll go into the formula one race,
maybe going to see Louis Hamilton wrap it up.
Um,
I've been so fucking busy.
I haven't been watching the moto GP.
I did see that fucking highlight of a mock Marquez,
uh,
passing.
What does David Coc divisio.
So it's the oca one of the great fucking names of all time and I always screw it
up in the rain.
Fucking passed them on one of the final turns.
It's just such a tremendous sport.
And,
uh,
whoever the fuck it was in my podcast that suggested that I should watch it.
I want to thank,
I want to thank you.
Um,
what am I up to here at 29?
God Damn minutes.
Um,
all right.
I had such a fun time argue in politics and in the end,
uh,
you know,
a hug,
the other person could come on.
All right,
we're all Americans here,
right?
Everybody relax.
Stop watching CNN 24 hours a day or watching Fox News 24 hours a day.
What you do is you watch him each 12 hours,
right?
And then you balance out you fucking propaganda.
You know what I mean?
Then you go to an NFL game,
you watch them sell your war.
You know,
it's sort of like a,
what?
We'll go war rally before the game.
They do everything but actually asked you to buy war bonds.
Um,
I think that's the Pentagon,
making sure everybody stays on the same page.
We don't end up with the Vietnam here.
They don't need a,
we don't need a bunch of fucking hippies out there.
Bernie,
they're puking draft.
God,
you get me get up and just say,
just get everybody out there to support the troops.
And uh,
I dunno,
I'm a cynical mother fucker,
you know,
I feel like they use in those kids.
I'm probably wrong.
I am a fucking idiot.
But,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno about that one.
At the very least,
at the end of all of it,
even if the Pentagon and everybody's heart is in the right place to fucking NFL
is making money off of it and it's so fucking gross.
It's gross.
Just stay in your own lane.
Okay.
You know.
Hey,
you know what the,
you know,
the NFL has in common with their fucking military.
They don't take care of that veterans either.
Oh,
I'm not right.
I'm done.
I'm fucking around with you guys.
See if I get a little bit of hate mail.
All right.
You want to talk music for a second?
You write finally downloaded.
I downloaded,
uh,
I can never met.
Not a love supreme
steak on you staying Connie.
It was Andre 3000,
and then there was the other guy.
Yeah.
I just downloaded cause I like the fucking trumps,
you know,
my brain doesn't work fast enough
for some of them.
To me,
this is modern music.
I'm so far behind.
It's,
it's,
it's fucking ridiculous.
What the hell did I,
uh,
did I download?
What does the name Stanko not stink on you?
What the fuck is that?
That's not what it's called.
Is it outcast?
This has to sound like you fucking parents.
You know why I like,
I liked that.
The,
the outsider status outcast.
Um,
not even then because this is like fucking 20 years old at this point.
2017 years.
Yeah.
Stank on yet.
There you go.
And I gotta be honest with you.
I downloaded this shit because I thought that this would be a good bass drum
exercise right here.
That's it.
Yeah.
Go,
go,
go.
Denka uh,
dead.
Dead.
[inaudible] dead.
Just do that for fucking an hour then.
Could I play good times,
bad times?
I Dunno.
Bill,
would anybody give a shit?
Yeah.
Hi.
All right,
I'm going to stop here.
I'll probably get the advertising later on tonight.
No fucking,
I'll go to read that.
Um,
does the Thursday afternoon podcast just before Friday,
Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in on you,
seeing how your week is going.
Enjoy the Thursday night football.
All right.
Support your candidate.
Support the troops.
Support the global warming.
[inaudible] sign with the Lakers.
Can we just do the whole fucking ramp up here?
It's better to break an ankle then the blow out a knee.
That's basically the physical,
uh,
burden of hands.
Better than two in the bush.
Oh look who's here.
Look who's here with a shirt that says flawless.
You know what?
I agree.
Isn't that just,
you know what,
what is about what I just said there and here?
It was sweet,
but it wasn't,
it just a little too sweet.
It wasn't just a little too on the nose now and I don't think so.
No,
you believed it.
What do you say?
You weren't being genuine?
Well,
I am like aware that there's people listening to this CD or phony.
there's going to be an element of phoniness.
I see.
Are you on the mile with their yak?
I don't know what that means.
Sorry.
I thought he thought with that yet.
30 so with that hint dog,
he said that's it.
Yeah,
but he says I'm one half mile with that yet.
To me that's good weather and he's on the back of a yak is literally on a Yak
and Yak.
In my world,
in my white world,
a yak is either you puked from drinking or instead farm animal.
I've never seen.
Right.
No.
Actually we saw at that time we went out to that,
that wine winery that also had the zoo's for tax purposes.
Malibu wines advisory.
A lot of people don't know that.
If you actually,
if you have a giraffe skin,
sorry.
If you have a giraffe on your property and you actually lowers your taxes,
unless you have to have a certain amount of kids coming by looking at it going,
whoa,
mom,
that's great.
Then the government goes,
oh,
all right.
All right.
Remember that girl got bit by the,
by the camel.
What?
You don't remember when the girl got bit by the camel kind?
Oh,
that group of girls did see broads in front of us and the guy goes,
all right.
Uh,
if you go to feed the camels and you run out of food,
make sure you're not basically within their,
their camel
was it?
And it was at a Llama.
Yeah.
Isn't like a,
a camel's a Lama with like osteoporosis,
isn't it?
It's got,
it's got lumps.
Right.
Personally,
my favorite outkast album.
Why are you,
why are you looking at that?
Oh,
cause I downloaded it just cause I like the bass drum.
okay.
This,
this bass drum.
Oh,
ready
to go?
Good.
MMM.
Yeah.
Do you not remember that he whatever the fuck it was.
It was something,
yeah.
Not from this country.
Right.
Lamas don't have the green card.
Do they?
Is Trump getting rid of them too?
I'm probably,
I stand with the llamas.
They're filthy that rapists.
Yeah.
They take now the jobs that are eaten all the grass.
Right,
exactly.
Then all the cows are like,
oh,
fucking forum.
Um,
is that a fat joke?
I don't think it was.
Anyway,
so he tells him whatever the fuck it was.
It was alarm or if I got an a guess three animals.
It was either a camel.
I think it was a camel.
Okay.
Um,
so the beginning of a joke,
a camel along camel and a Lama and a giraffe are all at a winery.
So the guy on the fucking,
the guy was dressed like a,
the man with the yellow
hat says to these dead tends to everybody in the fucking truck.
He was getting dressed the way they are.
They always dressed with those safari closed and then not doing anything is
you're just riding in a truck with me.
You could we wearing sweatpants,
the yellow hat.
Ah,
Doug is jarring.
Oh,
curious George.
I'm curious.
George W.
Bush.
Um,
so he says,
he tells these ladies,
he tells everybody,
he goes,
if you run out of fucking whatever the fuck we were feeding them,
make sure you're not in their wheelhouse because then they just going to chomp
down on you.
Uh,
because they're,
they're lunatics,
right?
So I forget what the fuck he said.
So these,
these,
these ditzy ladies go over there and she tries,
she runs out of fucking grass.
And then she turns around and tries to do a selfie in this thing came down and
just chopped her shoulder.
She kind of pulled away quick enough.
I remember she had some sort of,
yeah,
just like nipped her or whatever it was.
Yeah.
That was the greatest thing ever.
She came back to the track like,
oh my God,
it's,
you see that it's just totally good.
My shoulder,
and then the fucking curious.
George Guy had shades on and he just so everybody can hear it.
He just went,
I fucking told you.
I was like,
I love this guy.
Well,
I fucking told you.
There you go.
But that was a good time.
We went from mom's birthday.
That was nice.
Yeah.
If you want to get shit faced again and look at a Yak,
I mean I'm up.
There was a yak there.
Was there.
Yeah.
Agony.
Yak.
Okay.
No,
you're supposed go.
Don't talk back.
[inaudible]
can imagine all those people who learned to play the fucking saxophone in the
50s thinking like that was never going to end.
There was always a saxophone solo and then all of a sudden it just fucking
ended.
You know,
unless you were in Chicago or a earth,
wind and fire,
who else had them?
Lionel Richie's ban it,
right?
The commodores.
Yeah,
he was a horn player,
wasn't he Lionel Richie?
Yeah,
I dunno.
Nia.
What?
Oh my God.
You've been with me too fucking long.
How do you not know that?
How do you,
you're supposed to know everything that is black.
Seriously.
Am I supposed to know everything about the commodores,
commodores,
and I love it.
Go easy.
Like Sunday morning.
Sorry.
Let me see something.
I'm gonna look this fucking shit up right now.
This podcast is officially over you just fucking hanging out with this right
now.
Lyondell quiet
Lionel Richie Horn.
Lionel Richie's a video video
lion.
Which you are a song.
I know he played the fee.
Played some cover now
was it saxophone?
There's only so many orange,
right?
I mean there is,
there's not an infinite amount of horns.
Saxophone,
Lionel Richie Saxophone,
the Alto Sax.
There you go.
Wait.
Does he play it?
No.
And he was in the Commodore's.
He was like,
he was,
he's like Phil Collins.
Phil Collins is playing drums and I'm suddenly singing,
but I don't know.
I don't think he played at Lionel Richie.
Oh,
that's somebody playing hello online.
Although sec.
No,
but he played the fucking horn.
Fine evidence.
Where are the receipts?
Do you want to bet?
Yeah.
How much?
Five bucks.
Come on.
20 bucks.
But you 50 bucks.
$50 on whether Lionel Richie played the saxophone.
That's so dumb.
I know we did.
No he didn't.
Yes he did.
Isn't that funny?
You're scrolling through Google images cause I'm not,
I'm not,
I didn't single image of Lionel Richie playing any kind of Horn,
French Saxo
uh,
any of that.
Saxo
hello my doors.
Orange section.
Here we go.
You motherfucker.
He didn't take clay the horn.
I've seen the video.
He could play it.
Find it.
Oh look,
there he is playing the piano.
He's multitalented.
Well,
we know that could probably cook too.
I know we did.
It doesn't look like it.
Well,
none,
none of these are picked there.
That's not Lionel Richie.
Plant any kind of horn.
Oh yeah.
Who the fuck is that?
That's my line.
All right.
I know he did it.
I know we did.
I know I saw it.
I'm out.
50 bucks.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
What about
somebody listening to this knows without a doubt.
If I'm right or if I'm wrong and they're going to let me know.
You're on Google right now and those nothing that has come up.
Yeah,
but I'm a moron.
Well,
obviously.
Oh really?
At Jesus
[inaudible]
I know we did.
I know.
I saw him playing the fucking thing.
Wait,
who's who's the lead singer of the commodores?
Cause it wasn't him.
I that I do not know.
All right.
Fuck this commodores.
Brick House.
And I think this is going to be him on the fucking orange.
Gaco [inaudible] pain it,
Huh?
Okay.
Oh Gee there Brett.
Oh,
that makes you know,
I swear to God,
someone who can't sing because that said fucking hipster white fucking silver
lake horse.
Shit.
It's so bad.
It's good.
Okay,
here we go.
Where's Lionel?
I'm telling that's him right there.
I'll show you that.
I'll bet you 100 bucks.
I'm gonna come.
Ah,
no,
we already settled on 50
day.
Just letting it all hang out.
I'll show you.
But brick
got the black dot on the snare.
Very Seventies.
Come on,
holding nothing back.
He's right there with a saxophone.
Shh.
Sorry.
My daughter asleep.
That same with the sex phone on my dude.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Wait,
I wish I was playing it though.
Maybe he's just like posing.
Go Fuck Yourself Nia.
Oh my God,
it's him.
That's 50 bucks.
Sub My pup in the cow.
Alright,
that's the end of the podcast.
Woo.
That's how you make friends.
The bugs off your wife.
All right,
I'll talk to you fuckers on the weekend on Monday and joy.
Yah,
I guess I'm going to do a read after this in the future.
Ah,
right.
All right.
We get it.
She's got a nice ass.
Um,
oh my God.
Ulysses s grant baby.
He's on the 50.
Oh,
another white man.
Um,
well the hipster beard.
Who Knew?
Um,
that's it.
All right.
Uh,
enjoy.
the you fucker weekend,
you coach and a joy.
The,
uh,
Thursday afternoon podcast some Thursday sometime too.
Cause I did that.
I won 50 bucks after.
Finally we once in a while.
You're right.
Alright.
Fuck off.
[inaudible] Hey,
what's up?
I'm back.
Here's the fucking read here.
Lift everybody.
Lyft knows that their drivers are what keeps them moving.
Oh Geez.
They're really on it aren't they need so they do everything they can to make
sure where their drivers are happy on every trip.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that believes in treating its people better.
Lift believes that being a ride,
sharing drivers should be fun if you're having a good time.
So are the passengers.
Lift was also first to offer in APP tipping.
When you drive for Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers have been paid over $200 million in tips since the feature was first
introduced.
Express pay lets drivers get paid almost instantly instead of waiting weeks.
Almost instantly there's a loophole there.
Lift has even taken the guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp amp device uses color coding to help passengers find their driveway.
You could earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips.
One,
earn more money,
drive mower.
It's never been easier to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers mean happy passengers.
That's why nine out of 10 Lyft riders,
Nia,
get a perfect five star rating and go to lift.com/bird today,
l,
y,
f,
t and you can get $500 a $500 new driver bonus.
That's lyft.com/burr
lyft.com/burr limited time only terms applauding.
All right,
his read number two thaw.
See meow.
Everyone at some point has wished they could have.
They could just have beer,
wine,
or liquor delivered.
Yeah,
me too.
I just wish I could sit in the sun and drink.
Are you random Wednesday,
one Wednesday a month?
Did you can just get drunk in public?
Can you get your little cards to the cops cannot arrest you.
Well,
someone finally decided to do something about it.
Uh,
introducing Southie.
Meow.
The alcohol delivery apps thoughtfully delivers your favorite wine and beer and
liquor right to your door on demand.
If you're ever going to drink yourself to death,
this is the way to do it.
It's Uber.
Nobody would have to see it.
It's Uber for alcohol.
Now,
lift just said,
don't say Uber and they're fucking read.
And then saucy says.
Now if you're in Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
Chicago,
San Diego,
Sacramento,
you're saucy order will arrive at your door in 30 minutes or less,
ready to drink.
Of course,
this comes out when I'm on the wagon.
Oh my,
I,
I'm fucking getting this apnea.
I'm getting this up for the rest of us.
Saucy.
We'll deliver beer and wine,
liquor to your door in two days or less.
Nationwide.
There are no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
If you got the saucy APP,
you've got a fully stocked bar on your phone and for a limited time you can get
$15 off when you download the Southie App and enter the Promo Code burpee.
You are that saucy APP spelled s.
So I see and enter Promo Code [inaudible] I was wondering,
you gonna Laugh at that for $15 off.
Get this to
Stf Sulawesi
get this us app today and use the Promo code birth
officer.
Officer.
I'm not drunk,
I'm just so I see.
All right,
legal zoom,
everybody as a business out there,
you know how important it is to keep moving forward.
But what about that person who just died?
Just grab his briefcase [inaudible] but a lot of times things come up to take
your time and focus away from your growing business.
So when it's time,
when it comes to reviewing contracts,
registering for trademarks are staying current on fees and permits.
Legal zoom.com can can help simplify your life.
Legal Zoom was created 16 years ago by the brightest minds in law and technology
law,
Ology,
and they've helped more than 2 million business owners easily and affordably
navigate the legal system with confidence.
What's the best part?
You may have asked,
you'd never have to worry about a fucking attorney's bib billable hours piling
up because legal zoom is not a law firm.
Instead you get the advice you need to answer your business questions at fixed
rates through legal zooms,
nationwide network of independent attorneys.
Yeah.
So take some pressure off yourself.
Go to legals on.com now to take care of your business before the year winds
down.
Sorry,
I didn't know that was gonna be an explanation point.
And for several for special savings,
be sure to enter code bar in the referral box at checkout.
These are all exclamation points in year.
I don't know why that code Burr for special savings only at Ziegler.
legalzoom.com legalzoom.com
all right,
that's it.
Enjoy the Thursday throwback podcast.
[inaudible] Thursday come while ago.
Mama
car door.
Hashi his shit Glam or checks on
birthday.
It's been weeks since I got up.
First Father Tim to silence sometimes just be
shipped around the diamonds from psalms route down to
wait.
The
[inaudible] has got 21 I spoke
[inaudible] on the back down again.
Oh it's Columbus Day.
Alright.
Columbus Day.
It's Columbus Day.
He came over here.
There was already people he cut off the fucking hands cause they couldn't find
gold and we celebrate him cause he was kind of white even though I think he was
from Spain.
And if he came to Boston and try to get a job,
he'd be really fucked with most of the people he'd interview with.
Um,
let's,
um,
so yeah,
today it's Columbus Day.
Christopher Christopher Columbus.
Sorry.
I went to the brewers,
say had a couple of beers,
their rights to deal with me.
Christopher fucking cake.
Chrissy,
get on the fucking boat.
Do the job we paid you for Christopher Columbus.
Alright.
Discovered America Fall you volume people who have never picked up a history
book.
He sale in 1492 he sailed the ocean blue.
He thought he was going to the West indies.
This is like there once was a man from Nantucket there once was a man from
Spain,
a wet and his balls,
a pain.
He couldn't get laid.
He tried every day.
So he said,
fuck it,
I'm going to sail.
So I have something to talk about.
I don't know guys.
This is funny to me and I'm buzzing pretty fucking good and I really don't give
a shit.
I do give a shit.
I care.
I care about you.
And how did you enjoy Columbus state?
What did you do?
Did you put on like a fucking George Washington wig and stand on the neck of the
tennis person that you know,
in celebration of all the great things he did.
Um,
I've always had difficulty once I got past a certain age with the fact that that
guy,
they said he discovered,
he discovered like he discovered it for Europe.
He didn't discover it.
There was already people here.
You know what I mean?
Just sitting here living off the land,
you know,
a little mud flap over that junk using up every bit of the animal.
They did nothing wrong.
That's the overcorrection of native Americans where they've now become like
these godlike people where none of them were bad.
You know,
none of them would have fucked you out of your four zero one k money had they
understood what a 401k was and could tie a tie.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
people are people.
Let's,
let's,
let's get down to brass tacks here.
People.
All right.
Just because you sit in their philosophy with the fucking bison tendon doesn't
mean that,
you know,
if you had a car,
you wouldn't get a little grabby on the first date.
All right?
Okay.
And if you can't do the math on that,
that I can help you.
Um,
yeah,
it's Christopher Columbus Day.
Mary,
go Vespucci remember all,
let that fucking awful history stuff.
You sitting there with half a fucking erection looking at some chick next to you
and there's some guy in a Goddamn tweed coat talking about a Vinny del Negro.
What was he yelling?
What was,
what was the other guy?
The other world explorer.
It was a merry go Vespucci it was Christopher Columbus and then there was a guy
who had like a Vinny del Negro name,
but it wasn't Vinny del Negro.
But though that's in my head,
so I'll never be able to think of what the fuck was it?
Was it Marcus?
The Lafayette?
Was that him?
And he wasn't the trader in the revolutionary war.
That was benedict Arnold.
Marcus the Lafayette.
Did he start Marquette University?
He did something.
He wasn't with Lewis and Clark.
I don't fucking know.
You know what's funny is just all the shit that was done to create this country
and they kind of boil it down to like 14 people.
These guys sailed up a river.
This guy found it.
This guy said,
I can't tell a lie.
And a the other guy said,
hey,
why don't you lay off the black people for a minute?
You know?
And that's pretty much the first 200 years of history in this country as far as
I can tell.
You know?
And for all you Europeans listening and all you Australians,
that doesn't mean your country's better.
Alright,
so fuck you when your fish and chips and your vegemite sandwiches because nobody
gives a shit.
All right?
You just just felt these,
we are
good
in
months
in the summer,
the body's waking,
I've been
with
smoking,
can't protest without getting teargassed shot at you
all around the world.
You know,
they act like you,
you know,
we want to hear from our people and you go out there,
he just sitting out there,
all you doing it,
you got signs in your chanting and then the cops come down there and they start
pushing people around and they throw fucking tear guests.
I don't understand why,
why can't you do that?
Why aren't you allowed to protest?
Look,
I understand if you go down there and you start breaking windows in that type of
shit.
Uh,
but I,
I actually believe,
and I know you guys are gonna think that I'm paranoid.
If I was in power,
I would just say,
hey,
how old you kiss sun is set them out there and have him throw a rock through a
window so we could look justified when we get rid of these fucking people out
here.
Um,
Adam,
I'm sorry,
I'm going back down the fucking rat hole again.
Somebody sent me a great rant that this guy went on,
on a news program and he was talking about the bankers.
Uh,
cause I can't even watch the news right now with our government might shut down
in a couple of days with this guy was basically going off saying all that banker
shit.
I was trying to say a few years ago when I started watching those videos and
everybody was saying,
Oh yeah,
these are fucking fat guys living in their mother's who?
A,
they don't have any lives.
And you just,
you know,
you're drinking the Koolaid and all this shit that look,
a lot of that stuff.
We never landed on the moon.
I'll give you all that shit.
Yeah,
okay.
Maybe all of that stuff.
Nine eleven's in inside job.
I'm not talking about any of that fucking crap,
but that banker shit,
I'm telling you,
that banker shit is dead on,
dead fucking on.
It's not the left.
It's not the right,
it's those cuts right in the middle with money on both sides of the ball.
It's those guys.
And um,
I have to tell you,
dude,
the fact that the president only makes 400 grand a year and it just,
the way they frame it,
like,
oh,
he's a public servant.
And bookbub.
It's the biggest crock of shit out there.
The only person who would take that job,
you'd have to be the biggest fucking yes man on the planet just to get there.
Yeah.
Who the fuck would run for a job where it cost 100 million to get it so you can
make 400 grand a year.
Yeah.
That isn't a red flag to anybody.
Then you get to go around giving speeches,
a million dollars a whack like that.
Isn't he a kickback for fucking pushing through whatever they wanted.
I just think it's,
it's so beyond corrupt.
MMM.
And I used to think shit like I can't believe we're letting these pencil pushing
banking policies push us around,
but it's not them.
It's the fact that people will do anything for money.
So when you have that kind of money,
you can hire psychos and uh,
you know,
I dunno,
you get that.
You get that Lincoln town car ride the convertible in Dallas.
All right.
I spoke about it vaguely,
but you know what I'm saying?
Slow down.
Watch the spin around freedom.
Wait,
the Dan
[inaudible] got 21 that's
the hand gun down the back down
again.
[inaudible]
going on.
It is a bill burn it just the Monday morning podcast and it sounds really
fucking loud.
Why is that?
Cause my volumes up.
There we go.
I'm not red lining.
Mia.
Hello.
Test One,
two C.
I usually do that part before I get on the fucking thing.
But I didn't,
I didn't this time cause I'm doing it,
uh,
on Sunday night because for some reason I have the whole apartment to myself
other than my dog chilling out and a whatever.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
How are you?
Oh,
that's fantastic.
I'm actually in a great fucking mood.
I don't sound like it.
I'm in a great mood.
You know why?
Because,
well,
because of a number of things.
Okay.
First of all,
as any man,
a happy story,
I just don't want to forget to tell this story.
I was out at a friend's birthday party and a ranting about the Yankees.
Of course,
my hatred of the Yankees.
It's literally,
it's getting embarrassing.
It's like at a child like level.
Um,
I th I get infuriated every time somebody brings up the Yankees and they don't
mention that they've spent $200 million.
Why wouldn't they be up two games to none over the fucking angels?
Okay.
It just annoys me.
You know,
I already fucking,
I just,
but I have to stop because people out here don't give a fuck.
And I'm talking to like some guy from fucking Milwaukee and he's like,
yeah,
you know,
uh,
you guys kind of take our players too,
so I don't really give a shit.
And I'm like,
no,
but the Yankees are in our division.
What do we,
what the fuck are we supposed to do?
You know,
we're trying to end an 80 year curse that one fucking time,
right?
This pen a tour to million dollars.
What are we supposed to,
baseball's not stopping him.
What the fuck was he?
Look,
here I go again.
Here I go again.
Just like that awful Whitesnake song.
So anyway,
so I'm at this birthday party,
right?
I'm sitting there,
I'm having a couple of Budweiser's,
you know,
because I want to,
and this lady comes over,
you know,
it's the birthday time.
Happy Birthday dear touche bag.
Right?
And they bring that it's not a douche bag,
but they bring the fucking cake over.
Okay.
And then little Susie,
Miss uh,
cunty box starts cutting up the fucking cake.
You know,
there's always that fucking,
you know,
soccer mom to be,
who just has to all of a sudden start fucking running things like the fucking
control freak that she is.
So I'm sitting there drinking beer and she comes over with this fucking piece of
cake and she just sets it down here.
You want a piece of cake?
And I'm like,
no,
no I don't.
And she goes,
why not first red flag.
Then I'm dealing with a pushy comment.
Would you like some cake?
No.
No I wouldn't.
Why not?
Because I,
you fucking asked me that and that's what my inside said.
No,
I don't want cake.
I've got to give you a follow up find.
You want to follow up fucking answer.
I'll tell you why.
Because the cake is blue.
It's a blue cake.
She goes,
that's not the cake.
It's the,
that's just the die.
And she walks away and leaves the cake there.
Stupid as fuck and response ever.
That's not the cake.
It's the dye.
You mean the dye in the cake?
Oh,
I all,
I go,
oh,
I get it.
All I do is just eat the cake part.
I don't eat the blue part.
Exactly.
Where do I enter the cake to get to the part that actually looks like fucking
cake and doesn't look like a,
you spilled one of those roofie drinks on it.
Oh,
just fucking annoyed me.
And then I'm watching a bouncing around just handing people cake with his stupid
skirt and her smart looking fucking shoes.
You know,
little miss fucking PTA.
She just,
she does look like the kind of fucking broad that,
you know,
he's got nothing better to do.
This is,
this is her future.
She's going to have a couple of fucking kids and she's going to be all involved
in the fucking school and she's going to know everybody's God damn names and
just ah,
and it's just going to be her agenda and her agenda is going to fucking pass,
you know,
the same way I said no to the cake.
And this twat takes,
does not take no for an answer.
Would you like some cake?
No,
I wouldn't.
You know,
why is it socially unacceptable for me?
I should have just picked that fucking piece of cake up with the plate and just
mushed it.
I said I didn't learn any right in their fucking face there.
My faith is blue.
Oh,
that's just the die fucking Douche bag.
So anyways,
sorry.
I had to get that out.
I actually had a,
had a great week,
you know,
um,
as most of you know,
I had a,
uh,
had a bad experience on us air this past week.
They charge 25 bucks for the first bag and a,
when I landed,
I had to wait almost an hour to get my bag,
you know?
And I actually got the email and I promised you guys I was going to complain to
him.
You know,
and I know what you guys are probably thinking,
oh,
it's a fucking corporation.
What the fuck are you going to do?
This is what I did.
Okay.
You know,
because you have to,
I'm telling you,
you have,
we have to start looking at the psycho.
I'm actually using the word weak,
which I never do.
I believe that,
uh,
people need to start questioning some of the,
some of the demands that these corporations are making on people because it's
getting ridiculous.
You're sitting on a flight,
there's 300 people on the flight.
Nobody wants to pay 25 bucks for the first bag yet everybody does because
nobody's bitching or they take the,
uh,
every man for themself route.
Well,
I'll just fucking bring one shirt and a jock strap and that way I'll shove it
underneath the seat and I'll save my own ass,
you know?
And those of you who do that,
your own little selfish fucking way,
I hope you're married,
that chick with the blue cake.
Um,
so anyways,
as you notice,
I have a temper.
If you're new to my podcast and I don't give a fuck,
I think it's refreshing to sit here and do,
that's the kind of shit that kills you.
A little blue KC moments fucking kill you after.
Why you just hold onto it and it's like,
well she is kind of pushy and then you slowly just start eating the fucking
cake,
you know,
sound of children's wet feet running across concrete as you sit there and that
stupid fucking hourglass shaped pool right outside of that.
And is that what you guys do out there in the suburbs?
Some sort of rock formation,
artificial waterfall.
Um,
anyways,
what the fuck am I talking about?
See,
what you have to do is you have to learn how to complain to these corporate
fucks.
Okay?
Um,
like here's an example of someone who actually writing,
you know,
what do I really have time to read that?
Do I want to read it?
What do you guys want to do?
You want to hear the way not to do it?
Like one of those old little fucking school film strips?
You know Eddie,
correct way,
Susie.
Wrong way.
All right,
here's the wrong way.
A bill.
Here's a story regarding,
uh,
poor service.
About two years ago,
I took my,
uh,
my family wife and two sons,
ages six and four at the time,
social security number's nine,
seven,
eight up to New Hampshire in a,
the white mountains.
And we went to the wild west themed amusement parks so we could have some fun.
Now,
generally,
I'm a pretty angry guy,
but I try not to be so fucking miserable around my kids because I don't want
them to be the same as me.
So I try and act like a normal human being and let shit go when I get a,
when I get fucked to a certain degree.
Dude,
I can't even tell you how much I relate to that,
you know,
of course my wife will encourage this as well.
Um,
just calm down.
Everything will be all right.
I don't understand why he gets so upset.
Um,
he literally said,
insert your chip voice there.
Of course,
you know,
I was going to do that.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
we decided it's time to get some lunch at the old wild west show and we go into
some shitty little pizza stand inside the park that's in quotes.
You can already feel as anger.
Um,
and the line's pretty long,
but,
uh,
it's lunch so it's expected.
I then tell me wife and kids to wear it outside as I will order for the kids.
And so the kids don't get antsy,
you know,
take them over to some fucking struggling actor dressed as Winnie the pooh while
I go get the pizza slices.
Basically.
This is how I'm going to start compensating for my fucking bed.
Reading out loud skills is,
I'm just going to start paraphrasing anyway.
So,
uh,
as I waited about 20 minutes to order,
I'm looking at the cluster fuck that's going on and passing for an organ
organization behind the counter.
Um,
apparently some mid 40 ish year old douche bag who does the hiring has decided
it would be great to hire all 20 year old chicks or chicks in their twenties
with Russian based,
uh,
from Russian,
from Russia,
based on their hotness.
Sorry guys.
Um,
and they were pretty hot.
Well,
I'm a married man with my wife and kids with me.
So at this point I don't give a fuck how,
uh,
um,
I don't give a fuck as I'm not banging any of them anyway.
So I finally ordered and I began to wait.
After about 40 minutes of waiting,
my oldest son comes in and tells me his mother sent him to us where the food is.
Now,
keep in mind that this is a full 60 minutes with no food in his mind.
So I tell him to go back and I'll be out soon.
Now my wife sends him back because she doesn't want to lose the prime dirty
table that she is cleaned herself up.
Those amusement park tables are the worst.
So I ask in a polite way,
when my food will,
we,
when my food will be ready,
can't even fuck,
and this Russian looks at me and says in five minutes,
I then watch her go over there and reread my slip.
And then I watch your sprinkle the bullshit toppings that I asked for on my
piece of Cardboard Shit than I'm paying $25 for to begin with.
And she begins to cook it.
I then asked her if that's what happened,
basically saying,
did you forget my fucking order?
Um,
and she says,
no.
So I'm fucking starving.
And I'm furious.
So I start acting like a fucking asshole.
And I start talking really loud saying that I've been here for 40 minutes
waiting and I'm watching people leave before me who ordered after me,
and then I say,
just tell me,
Jill,
my phone's ringing in the other room.
I'd have to ignore it.
He goes,
ah,
just tell me that what you did.
Wait,
just tell me that you did one.
I know you did and that you made a mistake and that you just made my pizza.
You basically Joe Pesci in uh,
and casino.
I'm going to give you the money.
Just tell me you gambled you fucking degenerate piece of shit.
Right?
So it's at this moment as I should have realized that I'm 36 years old at the
time,
about six,
two and 200 plus pound yelling at probably a five foot 10 inch skinny Russian
chick who's about 22 years old.
But of course I didn't.
Um,
however,
some country,
45 year old chick sure did and starts,
I guess this is another customer and starts to button and tell me to leave her
alone.
I then blow up and tell her her mind around fucking business as well as you
should have.
Anyways,
I'm sorry,
that was a blue Cape woman seeping into this.
I tell her a minor on fucking business and stay the fuck out of it.
And I turn around to the other 25 people or so people waiting in our already
paid douche bag section,
holding our slips and I try to garner some momentum and say something like,
aren't you all waiting here to this?
This is ridiculous,
right?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Uh,
I was then,
I noticed my six year old with his eyes and mouth wide open looking at me and
either or shame,
I'm still not sure which.
So I asked you as another angry guide.
You think I should have just kept my mouth closed and continued to be part of
some fuck ups scenario in which some retard wants to fuck a young Russian and I
have to suffer by receiving poor service or continued to call out bullshit when
I see it.
All right?
See if you are 100% the right there.
Uh,
no.
You shouldn't start screaming and yes,
she shouldn't do that in front of your kid.
Um,
what you should've done it was you should have asked to see a manager and he
should've complained.
And uh,
what you should've done was basically,
there's a magic word that you use in there and it's not,
fuck,
it's unacceptable.
Okay?
You just have to keep your cool and you say,
listen,
I've been waiting here for 50 minutes for a slice of pizza.
Okay.
And when they go,
oh,
it's coming right up.
Just be,
it's unacceptable.
I just saw you put toppings,
you read my slip,
you put topics.
I feel that's what happened.
I want to speak to a manager and then when the manager comes over,
you just tell them in a nice,
calm tone,
what's going on,
blah,
blah.
That's the way to go about it.
And you just say,
I want some sort of compensation.
And when they say that they cannot give you any compensation,
you just keep saying that is unacceptable and you keep asking for people above
them.
If they are not there,
you get a phone number and when you get a phone number,
then you write a fucking email and you have to go that route.
And I swear to God,
good shit happens.
Why?
Why would I know that?
Because this is the second half of my a US airways story.
All right.
They basically,
you know,
they sent me to their Internet to complain that I had to wait an hour for my
fucking bag,
that I paid 25 bucks for it.
So I go onto their website.
All right.
I think I explained this last week.
So you know,
what do I get?
What do I get from these assholes?
They have a whole page where as I'm,
I'm trying to register to complain,
they're sucking out even more information.
So I've decided that that was unacceptable.
I'm not fucking doing that.
So I called the number and I called the people at,
at a US air.
I said very nicely.
I said,
look,
I understand that you,
you don't make the policy.
I'm not upset with you.
I'm upset with the guy sitting on the yacht with the US airways tie tack right
now.
Um,
sunning himself with my $25,
you know,
and a,
I want my money back.
And they said,
well,
go to the website.
I said,
I don't want to give you all that information.
And The lady said,
well,
that's the only way you can get your money back.
And I said,
well,
that's unacceptable.
I'd like to speak to somebody else.
So she gives me somebody else.
They tried to take me to the back to the website.
I say,
that's unacceptable.
I don't want to give you all that information.
There's no reason for me.
I have to give you all that information.
She goes,
well,
that's our procedure.
I said,
that's unacceptable.
So finally,
after just keep saying unacceptable and I wouldn't curse,
I didn't lose my cool.
I wouldn't get off the phone.
All of a sudden,
now all of a sudden they have some new direct email to give me to some person at
us airways and all you have to do is leave my name the flight I was on,
what the situation was,
and give them a callback number and they'll get back to me within two days.
So this is the letter I sent him.
I said,
my name is William Byrd.
I use William when I'm complaining.
Uh,
I flew us airways from uh,
Pittsburgh de Los Angeles connected here in Phoenix,
Arizona Sunday,
October 11th.
I paid the outrageous sum of $25 to have my first bag checked.
When I landed in Los Angeles,
I had to wait 55 minutes for my bag.
55 is capitalized as to stress that that is an outrageous amount of time.
Anyways,
I said,
at no time during the hour long wait,
did any employee of US Airways make any attempt to inform its customers as to
what the problem was?
When I finally found an employee,
I was told that US airways had employed a skeleton crew on this particular day.
In other words,
there were not enough people working that day to handle the workload.
Hence,
my girlfriend had to pay for parking at the airport and we had to sit for almost
an hour until the skeleton crew was able to get me,
get my bag to me.
I fly every other weekend and recently flew to Sweden with my girlfriend on US
airways.
As a loyal customer,
I need some sort of gesture on your part to show that you respect the fact that
I use your airline and that you care about the service that you provide provide.
Therefore,
I feel I am entitled to a full refund of my $25 bag fee.
I would like to be contacted at this number between the hours of this and this,
this Thursday,
October 15th to resolve this matter.
Sincerely,
William Burb,
blah,
blah.
All right,
so I'm all geared up.
I'm clearing my schedule for the four hour window.
Wait for this person to call fucking the next day I get an email.
Dear Mister Burn,
due to the circumstances of you have described,
um,
as a one time courtesy,
I have authorized a refund of your baggage fee.
Please allow up to 30 days for posting back to the original form of payment.
Okay?
First of all,
what I love about this shit is they act like they're doing me a favor.
Do the circumstances you have described as a one time courtesy.
Now,
this isn't a courtesy.
This is standard business.
This isn't a one time courtesy.
This is an every time courtesy.
I'm never waiting 55 minutes for my bag that I paid 25 bucks for.
That's unacceptable.
It's unacceptable.
Magic word people unacceptable.
But this is the great thing about corporations.
Even though I'm getting my money back,
they still gonna make me crawl through another hundred yards is shit.
This is the next paragraph.
While customer relations is unable to view our refund department's computer
system,
you may check the status of your refund via our website.
Uh,
click on the refund inquiry ink link.
Proceed to the check refunds status link on the following screen.
Input your 13 digit ticket number.
Please direct all future refund status in Greece.
Inquiries to our refund department.
So wait,
do I have to do all that shit?
They get my money back.
I guess that's the view,
the status of it.
It's gonna take like a month.
So,
uh,
but anyways,
there you go.
So I did that.
I asked for my fucking money back.
That is James Brown on the background
and I got my fucking 25 bucks back and I never quit.
Sorry.
I thought the,
I'm king quicker.
I can never be a DJ.
These fucking assholes,
man.
I got my fucking money back.
I had to go through a bunch of shit.
But I'm telling you,
the key word is to say unacceptable.
It's fucking unacceptable.
And you know what?
It is unacceptable.
It's unacceptable that you got to pay $25.
It's all bullshit there.
They're charging $25 you know why?
Because American Airlines did it and they got away with it and nobody fucking
complaint.
I'm not saying you have to fucking complain,
but you should.
All right.
Nobody is sticking up for regular fucking people.
And I hope this little,
we'll encourage you to complain.
What is wrong with my voice?
I've got too many shows.
How many times is it going to crack to complain when it's time to change and he
fucking Brady bunch fans out there.
So there you go.
I got my fucking money back,
I guess.
Although I have to check the status of it,
guarantee I don't get it back and then I got to remind them,
oh yeah,
that's right.
And then they sit in the conference room.
Jesus Christ,
he's part of the 0.1% who actually checked the status of his fucking refund.
So that's the new me.
That's what the new me does.
They knew me.
When I get fucked by a corporation,
I do not lose my shit and curse the way I do on this thing.
That's why I love this podcast.
I just vent.
Okay.
The new me is I basically,
I keep my cool and I just say that things are unacceptable and I want some sort
of resolution.
That's what I want.
And if you can't help me,
if I would like to speak to the person above you,
if there's no more person above you,
I want the name and number and email of the person that I can get in contact
with.
Okay?
So I can have a resolution to this problem.
I'm telling you that's the way you gotta do it.
So if I was at that park,
I mean sometimes you got to let it go.
I mean,
you're at,
you're at an amusement park.
Um,
I got to watch out.
My girlfriend's coming home,
going to make sure mom's not here,
so I can say gut bombs here.
That wouldn't be good.
Nino.
Hey,
what's up?
Are you by yourself?
Okay,
so I can say cunt and not offend your mother.
Yes,
I am back.
I'm getting the,
uh,
doing the podcast.
That's what I'm doing.
Where you're coming from.
What do you mean you're not here?
What are you supposed to be on?
Somebody else's podcast?
What do you achieve?
Not me.
Oh,
okay.
What did you say
you saw good hair?
Was it a good movie?
A good movie?
What is it about?
Is it about hair?
That's good.
Oh my God.
I really enjoyed it.
People had good hair and other people didn't.
But in the end we realize,
are we all just people?
I might have good hair,
but you have a better shirt.
Oh my God,
I have to call my brother.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I had a,
I actually had a great week.
I'm out here.
I was getting off the roads doing a stand up six of the last seven weeks.
So as I mentioned last week that my surprise from my lovely girlfriend was that
I was going to rent a corvette convertible for the day.
Yes.
Which is actually,
it was such a great gift because it was something that I could totally enjoy.
I'm going to tell you something right now.
I know.
Shut up.
You don't talk on the fucking podcast unless I talked to you.
What are you saying
was for you and
I got to participate in it.
Is that how you viewed that?
When I took you up to Pch,
the fucking Pacific coast highway people vacation,
they fly out here to do that and I took you up there and a corvette convertible
with the fucking top down.
Like goddamn Steve McQueen.
We rolled right up there.
We had a wonderful lunch.
We Watch people surfing out the fucking window on a,
on a,
on a w a Thursday,
Thursday.
Most people are at work.
It was awesome.
Have I spoiled you that bad that you take that for granted?
No,
I just,
I thought it was more like a presence then.
Why?
Why,
why are you belittling me on my podcast?
Well,
they don't you,
I just,
I just felt like it was more,
it was like a present for you that I got to participate in and I loved it.
But it was like
you listen to,
to uh,
try to warm her way out of this.
I know it was just,
it was you or you had been talking about the corvette and the doing the thing
like it was,
it was your thing that you really wanted to do.
And I was lucky enough that you allowed me to participate.
Yeah.
And then they come over and your kids.
Yeah,
and that makes it all better.
Right?
Sweet.
Get out of here.
See what you just,
I didn't have to do that.
I could've got that and I could've gone a could've gone by myself.
Huh?
What do you keep coming with me with that attitude?
Like we're not,
yeah,
I,
oh my God.
He really annoy me.
Then we went to the Hollywood hills and I took you like driving like fucking
James Dean and we thought we were going to go off the cliff,
but we didn't because of those fat fucking tires.
That a 22 times the size of the Prius.
It was amazing.
I wasn't trying to go live a lit just huh.
No,
you didn't know.
This is what you did.
All of a sudden you started acting like a Oh yeah.
It was really a present for you.
Yeah.
Obviously it was something I know I wanted to do,
but like I didn't mean like you were reading.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
You know what I mean?
You get,
you get the fucking car.
How much fun did you have?
I had a great time.
Was that not one of the best fucking days you've ever had?
That was one of the best days I've ever had.
Yeah,
100% exactly.
We spent the day together.
Yes it was,
and I spent all the money.
Right.
I'm sorry.
I should,
yeah,
there you go.
I would have gotten all dolled up.
If someone's going to take me for a ride in a corvette convertible,
I would have what?
A jerk.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm not going to lie to you.
It was for me also.
Oh,
there's one for you guys,
so that's what you do.
Next time a girl say,
you don't take me anywhere.
I'm telling you,
just go out and rent.
Rent the fucking why.
Guys need to hear that.
I'm balancing out the Oprah universe.
Oh,
shut the door.
Go fucking watch when he had dumped shows.
10 whores in a house.
What are you watching this week?
Huh?
Fucking 20 chefs try to compete to get the next fryer later job at Tgi Fridays
and they let themselves get belittled by some fucking chef because he has an
accent.
Do you know what,
if we ever have a fucking kid and he wants to be a chef and he goes on that show
and he lets that guy,
that hell's kitchen guy talk to him that way and not stab them with one of his
gins,
suse,
I will disown him as a son.
I'll disown him as his son.
He comes home and tells me he's gay.
Whatever,
be who you are.
I don't give a shit,
but you,
you do not let somebody fucking scream and yell at you like,
Hey fucking believe the way they do it.
I would make a fucking omelet.
Alright.
Cheese always holds its heat to and I would just mush it right in the guy's
face.
No,
I hate that show.
That show makes me fucking even angrier than I am.
What are you doing?
Get the fuck out of the kitchen to two inches from their face.
Ugh.
All right.
Get out of here.
Get out of the room or,
right,
you're fucking up the podcast.
This is really going good.
It's going good.
No.
Then then all of a sudden it becomes like a,
we're like fucking George Burns in that,
that brought,
he married that died before him.
You know,
I love about George Burns.
His wife died before him.
It's a very rare thing,
you know?
Why do you guys usually outlive us?
It's an inspirational story.
Kind of like when you watch that show with that chick who holds up the union
sign.
Remember her
Billy Joe McIntyre and what is her name
or his or her name?
Sally field.
All right.
That's why I said Billy Joel,
but I was talking about the actress.
Oh,
get out of here.
It's just fucking takes them forever,
Deena.
Okay.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna tell the story about you.
Me leaving today.
We'll then get outta here.
We'll grab your whole bag and get out.
Get Out,
get out of what you're doing.
Yes.
Can you close the door please?
See that I knew she was going to say no.
I had to give her one little bit of a victory as she went to leave.
That's how you do it.
So anyway,
so I rent this fucking car right now.
Those of you who are new to my podcast.
Um,
thank you.
Thank you sweetheart.
There's no reason to take the dog.
Uh,
really that's going to be like,
we get married someday.
We get divorced as Ellen Omen calling our Harry kid out of the room.
All right,
let's plow ahead.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Um,
one of the things I always wanted to do,
I've always loved,
I've always loved cars,
always loved the corvette.
So I just said,
fuck it.
I'm going to rent one costs 350 bucks for a day.
I know that's a lot of money.
All right,
but I'm telling you,
you're not gonna regret it.
I didn't regret one fucking dime of it.
It was one of the best days I ever had.
And he's a,
even as a redhead in the Goddamn desert,
I just put on some sunscreen.
I had a fucking hat.
I know.
I really just made myself look like a Douche bag.
Like,
I had a big fucking straw hat I didn't,
I had a baseball hat on and it was just fun.
It was tremendous.
I can't even describe it.
Going from a Prius to a Chevy corvette,
ash,
it was just fucking awesome.
And uh,
and they only gave me 50 miles.
This is why you got to love a recession.
I bumped it up to a hundred or can you give me a hundred?
And I was by ray say,
I'll pay you more than the guy goes,
all right,
I'll give you a hundred.
Right?
And you'd be surprised.
100 hundred miles is a lot of fucking miles.
It's a lot more than it seems.
And uh,
but I actually learned something if I ever could afford that Goddamn car,
I wouldn't get one out here because,
um,
there's just way too many people like during the day,
the fastest I could get the car going with 85 miles an hour.
And it was absolutely fucking terrifying because there were so many people on
the road.
Unfortunately,
I'm a 41 year old guy and I understand ramifications at least at that level.
And I'm just like,
this is stupid,
Bill.
You're going to hit somebody,
you're going to kill him and you,
you know,
your whole dreams going to go down the toilet.
So I fucking slowed down.
But at night that's a different story.
Night was a different story.
Put the top down.
I went up to Hollywood hills and I went through Mulholland where it's,
you know,
you feel like you're on top of the world,
and I drove like an absolute maniac and scared the shit out of Nia,
but she liked it on some level,
just an unbelievable fucking car.
And I don't know why I,
you know,
it's that Catholic fucking upbringing.
I bust my balls,
I work my ass off and I never get myself anything.
And finally I was like,
fuck this.
So,
um,
I don't know.
Long story short,
it was a great thing.
It's a great thing to do and uh,
you don't need to get the,
for the,
you know,
the Ferrari just to let you know,
the Ferrari and a Lamborghini,
which you can fucking rent.
It's 1500 bucks for the day.
So
this is what you can do.
You can get you in 15 [inaudible] 14 of your closest friends.
You all go in in it for a hundred,
then I would still suck.
Then you only get out,
you get a hundred miles divided by 15 Jesus Christ.
What'd you get?
Four or five miles each.
That would suck.
Has got to be a fucking way to do it.
It's gotta be a way to do it,
but I mean you get like a Porsche was like 900.
That's ridiculous.
But the Corvettes,
350 bucks.
Okay.
You know,
stop drinking for like a month.
That'll pay for at least half of it if even if you go to a dive bar.
Um,
definitely,
definitely.
That's my underrated,
underrated for this week.
Underrated is,
is,
you know,
spending some money on yourself for once for someone who doesn't do it.
So I don't know,
this whole podcast went off the fucking rails.
At some point.
Nia came in.
Um,
that really bugged me on sir.
And that was actually,
I was actually for you at some level.
Yeah.
Obviously it was,
but it was something we did together,
right.
Doesn't that matter?
You know,
I'm gonna tell the fucking story.
So we go to the gym this morning and I want to go watch the patriots game.
Patriots won 59 did nothing,
by the way.
And uh,
I dunno,
you know,
I don't want to say I called it,
but I said Sanchez when they were saying the star is born because he beat the
titans in the first fucking week.
I'm not saying that the guy's not going to be a good quarterback,
but what the fuck is with the New York media with debt skitzo fucking reporting
that they do these guys the greatest do ever.
Cause he wins one fucking game and then they go through,
you know,
and then they beat the Patriots when Brady still,
playing his first games after a year and a fucking half.
And did they destroy us?
They won like 13 to fucking seven and a fucking jet fans.
They're already talking super bowl.
And what happened?
Ah,
you lost the last fucking three games in a row.
Idiots.
It's stupid fucking firemen.
They gotta show him every five fucking minutes.
It's just the,
I hate people who dress up for football games,
which means I hate half the people in the Oakland Coliseum.
Half of them are called.
Half of them look like Ken Stabler the other half.
I know I've talked about this before,
but I just don't understand.
It's like,
are you remaking the thriller video?
Who Do you think you're intimidating with?
Your fucking plastic spikes coming out of your shoulder pads.
I had just,
why is my voice cracking shoulder pads
anyways,
so there you go.
Things are returning to normal in the AFC east and if you're a giant fan,
uh,
don't sweat that lost today.
I'm actually actually predicting right now the giants are going to beat the
saints in the playoffs just because they've been there before.
And Tom Coughlin is a great coach and he's going to use this loss to build on at
the end of the day,
you got your ass kicked in October.
Who?
You know,
who gives a fuck?
You're going to be fine.
Eli has that.
I Dunno.
I Dunno to look at his face.
You wouldn't fucking think I told you.
He looks like that kid who comes to school every day and he always has a fucking
cold.
There's just something about the way the helmet and has cheeks together that he
just doesn't look like he's going to get it done.
But I'm,
I'm telling you,
he just had a bad fucking game.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
Let's get on with the questions for this week.
Um,
all right,
Bill.
Uh,
I guess I have to jump right in.
It's kind of a long question here.
It's actually a story.
Um,
have there ever been times where you felt that you needed to be funny but the
situation you were in just left you feeling completely uninspired?
Like he had some unfunny script to work with or a,
you are working in some situation where you looked at the material given to you
and thought,
man,
there is no way I can make this funny.
Uh,
yeah,
definitely.
Especially with the acting stuff as I'm not established as an actor.
So I basically take any audition I can.
Um,
let me read the rest of us.
Uh,
I guess what brought the this question about is that I recently graduated
college and I'm attempting to make my way as a professional photographer since
I'm graduating at such a great time.
That's obviously sarcasm.
I had been left with some less than ideal job offers.
I did,
however,
managed to grab a job working as a photographer in some studio at an upper class
mall in northern Virginia.
Doe,
I'm happy to have a job.
This new found position is made me realize that there is an entirely different
dynamic to being a professional creative person than I originally thought.
Throughout my experience in photography,
I have always had full control over how things work.
I choose the people,
the locations,
how it's going to look and what kind of ideas are going to be conveyed.
But now I'm stuck in a limited studio shooting some of the most boring people
you've ever seen in your life.
Uh,
but basically this guy used to take photos from an artistic standpoint and now
evidently he's photo taking foot,
you know,
photos of people,
uh,
who I guess are the real life version of the office.
Um,
anyways,
to get back to his question,
he goes,
I guess I feel that,
uh,
this is a similar,
this is similar to comedy in that I,
I have always thought you have to kind of feel a joke when you're saying it.
If you thinking about it then you probably already fucked it up.
Dude.
That's a grip.
Brilliant insight.
Yeah,
that's exactly the way it is.
And there are times a,
yeah,
I didn't,
you know,
if I have an audition and the material is horrible,
what you,
what you do is you call it shine and shit.
You'd go in there and you try to make it as funny as you can.
And,
um,
I always think of Jim Carrey whenever I have a,
uh,
if it's like a comedy,
um,
if it's a comedy audition and I just think it's really not funny,
I usually start to Improv.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I always think of that beginning,
but I think the most brilliant bit ever,
one of the most underrated bits ever is the beginning of Ace Ventura part too.
When he's in that fucking Yak suit or water buffalo,
I dunno what he's in,
but he's filming some people doing some bad shit to animals and just
basically what happens is all of a sudden the fan or something inside the fake
Yak breaks and he starts getting so hot because he's in the desert or whatever,
the fucking Serengeti,
he starts taking off all of his clothes and it's still hot.
He's literally butt ass naked and the only way to get out of this fucking Yac is
to come out the back end.
He literally,
it looks like this Yak gives birth to a naked adult and the brilliance is he
comes out the back and he literally falls on the ground the way I've seen a baby
giraffe fall out of a mother giraffe and he's fucking totally naked.
It's,
it's one of the most brilliant fucking bits I've ever seen and it gets no
respect whatsoever.
When people talk about comedy,
and that's one of those things,
I just look at it and I'm like,
how did that,
how did that come about?
Was he watching the discovery channel?
He saw baby giraffe fall out of the back of it.
And that got his mind going.
Like,
what if I fucking fell out of the bag?
And I think that's one of those,
like those are the most brilliant jokes to me where I can't even find the
beginning point
of it.
Um,
so anyways,
I kind of use that guys is,
is like an inspiration.
Like he would totally commit to shit.
There's like legendary stories.
They had that guy going on auditions wearing his clothes on backwards.
He did everything.
A lot of fearless stuff.
So,
um,
if I was you,
when I was taking pictures of a bunch of boring people and my passion in life
was to be a photographer,
I would mock the,
silently mock the situation and I would put these people in ridiculous poses
that,
um,
they didn't notice were ridiculous.
And,
um,
I would secretly be keeping an album for yourself,
you know,
and keep some of the worst photos.
So as you're giving them the photos they want for their regional director of who
gives a fuck,
you're actually building a coffee book table.
Um,
coffee book table
coffee table book too.
I might do,
I might fucking just dyslexic without even reading.
What did I say?
A coffee book table,
a coffee table book your own private one.
Do that would be a,
that's what you work on for in the future when you become a famous photographer
and you need your,
and you're telling your inspirational story of how you got where you're at is
just start keeping this diary of,
of of horrific photo like photo shoots that she had to go on.
And you're gradually basically building a book,
you know.
So in the end when you have your famous ones have,
you know,
taken a picture of some navy guy
doing shit that you know nowadays would be sexual harassment.
Just grabbing a woman in,
jamming your tongue down her throat I guess.
Cause you take it in black and white that,
that makes it art,
whatever.
When you get that fucking picture and you make a name for yourself,
you'll have all this,
you know,
kind of like a comedian has like all this hell gigs stories and uh,
I just don't know what the rule is with the rights.
MMM.
You know,
do you have to the people that have to sign off to be like in the book,
don't you have like some sort of form that you own the rights for all these?
Are you working for these corporate cons where they own everything?
Fuck that.
Just make one on the side that'll make your friends laugh.
So as you're taking pictures of these boring,
stupid ass,
so can people in the back of your head,
there's a joy when it's awful because you're like,
oh,
that's going to be a great one.
You know,
it's like back in the day when I used to work in a dental office,
way back in the fucking day as I was,
you know,
certified to take x rays of people.
They'd say something fucking stupid.
I would write it on the Little Manila envelope and I would later,
I would try it later on that night and I used to get such a kick out of that,
that these people had no fucking idea that they were actually writing an act for
me.
Those are some of the,
my original jokes.
Did I ever tell you in some way original jokes?
They were basically a,
what the fuck was a joke?
I used to do
die and I don't know what the problem is.
I'm a,
I can't believe I got another cavity.
I mean,
I brushed my teeth almost every day and that was such a great setup to my
punchline,
my crude punchline of Oh,
yet do you wipe your ass almost every time you take a shit.
I had some clean ones back then.
I used to work clean.
One of my big lasts was a four years of neglect is not cured by a tic tac in the
waiting room.
Huh?
Isn't that clever?
That was one of my earlier ones,
so that's what I did.
That's what I did.
So you're basically working in the dental office right now.
So what you do is you,
yeah,
he just,
you know,
do this.
Just because you have this job doesn't mean you can't be doing something else on
the side.
That's what you do.
This is your hustle during the day.
You take pictures of fucking,
you know,
these boring as people.
And then on on the side,
you'd do your other shit,
you know,
and then somehow the whole thing fucking comes together.
And next thing you know,
it's Tuesday in the afternoon and you just decide,
I'm going to run a fucking corvette.
And you go do it in life is great,
you know?
All right,
let's go to youtube videos.
Uh,
here's some three funny youtube videos for the week.
all right.
Uh,
search this search Jack Chop,
uh,
somebody doing a fucking great Boston accent.
It's actually a great Halloween video.
Uh,
check that one out.
Here's another one to check out,
uh,
in quotes.
Second Checkout,
a shake weight,
s h a.
K e.
Wait,
w e I g,
h.
T.
And a.
Then for those of you who'd like to see a cute video,
checkout a search,
a kick my ask,
like,
I'm going to ask you a question.
It's an adorable kid.
Absolutely adorable kid talking about monsters kicking her,
ask.
Um,
and I think that's it.
I think that's it for the podcast this weekend.
I was a little bit short.
Um,
I got a little thrown off.
My girlfriend came fucking walking in and I kind of lost my whole train of
thought about who's kidding,
who I have no fucking game find for these goddamn things.
I'm exhausted.
I have a bunch of Shit I have to do tomorrow.
I have to try to get some fucking health insurance as my health insurance ran
out because I was on the road and I didn't make the payment.
And you have 8.2 days to make the payment.
So,
uh,
I'm just going to say fuck it.
I'm going try and get the best.
Uh,
yeah.
That's such assholes.
I already called these fucking people up.
It's such a goddamn racket.
You know,
Mike,
even the evening,
I'm not even bummed out that I lost my health insurance because my health
insurance basically covered everything except for what the fuck I went in for.
Right.
So I call up blue cross blue shield and I say,
look,
I just want to be covered for some shit.
I don't give a fuck how much it costs.
I said,
how about some dental?
I just want to be covered for dental cleanings.
Yep.
All dental cleanings Iraj are covered.
Dental cleanings are free.
You get two free cleanings a year or some shit.
And I'm like,
fantastic.
That's exactly what the hell I'm looking for.
So I can go to my dentist and get a free cleaning if I give you all this loot
every month.
So technically it's not even free.
Is that what the fuck you're telling me?
Well,
yeah,
they're part of the fucking provider.
Fucking cunty fuck,
fuck right.
And I find out they're not.
Yeah.
And basically that they,
that if they're not part of their list of dentists that I can go to what they,
basically the money that they give is a $55 for a cleaning.
Okay.
All right.
I Dunno what state you guys live in,
but there's no place in Los Angeles that I can get a cleaning for $55 that is
not in a strip mall and the person speaks fucking broken English.
It's such,
it's such a fucking scam.
You know what you're doing.
You're paying the vague just in case you get hit by a helicopter or some
bullshit.
But other than that,
it's the biggest fucking scam on the planet.
You know,
a buddy of mine told me a long time ago,
you go to the city,
what are the two tallest buildings you will we see.
Yeah.
You know,
all they're owned by banks and they're owned by insurance companies and they
don't get that way by fucking pay.
And people,
somebody sent me a great video clip to about microchips,
bought them microchipping people.
For all you guys who think I'm a crazy fucking conspiracy theorist.
Just go on the youtube,
go on the youtube,
go on youtube and a checkout.
Uh,
just search microchips,
human beings and look at some of the shit that they have coming out.
I wish,
I wish I could find with a fucking link was they showed this creepy commercial
of all these old people who's a entire,
um,
medical histories on the,
in is on a microchip that's in them.
And the doctors scans them and you know,
of course they fallen down so they can't explain what's wrong with them,
but he just scans them in.
Oh,
thank God.
Uh,
they,
they have a microchip in them so I know exactly what to do for them and there's
all these people sitting there,
you know,
given the thumbs up and it's really warm and fuzzy and it's delivered at this
speech where it causes you to stop thinking.
I'm telling you,
it's,
you feel like they're trying to hypnotize you.
It's all part of the end game people.
This is where I go off the rails and I lose most listeners.
It's all part of this new world order shit where they're going to have one world
government,
one world fucking bank and everything you ever fucking did is going to be on
this microchip.
All your money,
everything,
all you people out there who are accepting direct deposit,
don't fucking do it.
Go down their cash party a check,
use cash.
Don't get lulled into this.
Oh yeah,
it's easier to use your car.
I'm telling you that they're funneling the herd right down the shoot they want
them to go into and I'm telling you we're all going to be fucking microchipped
and then those,
you think those guys have us by the balls now if everybody is microchipped and
you can track where everyone is and all your money and financial shit,
all your information is on a microchip that is in you.
The second you fuck with the deal and you start complaining too much,
all they have to do is turn off your chip
and you'll instantly be homeless and you you can't revolt anymore and I'm sure
they'll have degrees of it.
There'll be the first warning shutoff where they shut off like two thirds of
your fucking bank account disappears or something like that.
Um,
I'm telling you guys that's,
that's way too much fuck at power.
I mean,
I don't know how to stop it,
but uh,
uh,
this is just fucking crazy shit.
I really believe that.
I am want to get into it.
I just,
I think we're headed
towards some crazy shit.
I suggest all of you rent a corvette now while you still can get yourself a pit
bull like me.
Um,
I don't know.
Get some powdered food and get a gun.
I wish I,
I wish I grew up with guns.
You know,
I wish he had a fucking gun.
What are you going to do?
You can't fight it.
You can't fight it because when the shit goes down,
they're going to sick your own fucking people on you.
Whatever organization they have.
I don't want to shoot a cop.
That's what I'm going to do.
Just some regular guy doing his job.
I don't fucking do that.
Well,
they round you up.
Do I sound fucking crazy?
I should cause I just made a huge leap right there where I would end up shooting
a cop.
I didn't explain like 40 other things in that scenario.
How that ends up going down.
Um,
I have no idea what the fuck I'm talking about.
I just know there's a bunch of crazy shit that's going on.
I don't know how to link it together.
Why do I have to be microchipped in the future?
Why do they have to know where I'm at at all fucking times and they keep selling
it to me.
Like they're trying to protect me.
They're not,
they're trying to get full fucking control over me and I don't like it the same
way.
I don't like dead
bitch telling me to eat that fucking blew cake.
I don't want you up my ass.
I'll defend myself.
Thank you very much.
There's enough control right now.
There was enough control.
That's it.
You already got those awesome planes.
We can fly to 2000 feet and nobody even knows and they can see if he just,
shit,
baby guys did use that on 60 minutes.
One of the coolest things ever.
Oh,
there's killing those fucking terrorists over there.
They're doing it like right out of like
way out there on like the Mojave desert or some shit.
I Dunno.
I think it's cool as hell.
That aspect of it,
you know?
And as long as they shoot and terrorist,
I have no fucking problem.
But I don't trust banks as far as you can fucking throw him.
And I think they're just slowly taken over the goddamn world.
I'm telling you,
people read up on the,
just read up on banks.
I'm too fucking stupid to explain this to you,
but read this book are the case against the Fed and just really read what the
Federal Reserve is.
Man,
it's really a frightening fucking thing.
This is what I want somebody to answer to me.
Where did all the gold go?
That's what I want to know.
You know,
back in the day,
gold was used as money,
but it was too heavy.
It was inconvenient and it was scary.
It was.
It was dangerous to carry.
So the banks cove will tell you what,
give us,
give us your gold and when you give it will give you these pieces of paper that
will represent the gold in anytime you want.
You can bring the pieces of paper in the cash and you can get your gold.
And at some point they took us off the gold standard,
but they kept the fucking gold.
They kept the gold,
they've never been audited and they can't be audited the way they're set up,
they can never be audited.
So do you honestly think that that goal is sitting there in Fort Knox?
I don't think it is.
I really don't.
I think it's just fuck it's fucking paper and it's the greatest crime in modern
history.
They got everybody to come down to the banks and give them their fucking life
savings and they cap it and in return they gave people pieces of fucking paper.
That's basically what's going on and now they can invent more pieces of paper.
I had satisfied as fucking ugly.
Why?
How did I get on this?
How did I get into this?
I don't know how I got into this.
The fucking lady with the blue KC pissed me off.
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Oh,
I know what I forgot to bring up.
You know something I love,
if you're still listening to this right now,
I love you for listening to this because I know why you're listening to this.
It's like a train wreck.
It's just fun to just sit here and listen to me.
Fucking slowly lose my mind and my little compound here.
Um,
this is the deal this week I'm going to be at the DC Improv,
uh,
the Improv in Washington DC.
For those of you who are our geographically challenged.
And um,
as of about four days ago,
all my shows are sold out there and in the business that's called going clean.
And when clean Thursday,
Friday and Saturday,
one show,
Thursday two shows,
Friday two shows Saturday,
sold them all out,
ridiculous support out there.
So I got a lot of emails of people saying,
you know,
if I had half a brain on what a hype us in the beginning rather than talking
about this chick with the blue cake.
Um,
so we added a second show,
a late show Thursday night,
and I'm really looking forward to that because what kind of a person goes out to
the late show to a comedy club on a Thursday night?
You know what my kind of person,
okay the kind of person who,
uh,
maybe it doesn't like job,
you know,
or maybe feels that they're not getting paid the way they should be paid and
maybe they've done enough work for the week.
Thank you very much.
You know,
I wrote a whole list of,
it came up with 10 reasons why someone would come out to see me on a late show.
Your boss is one of the three people in America that actually caught the swine
flu.
So now it doesn't matter what [inaudible] when you fucking roll in at 11 the
next fucking day,
you know,
was that three reasons?
Let's see if I can get up to 10 cause you've got to go to 10 for your,
uh,
your fucking,
your boss and he got him by the balls so you can go see a late show or your
bosses married and you know who he's fucking and he knows that,
you know,
so you can kind of,
you guy,
you've got a little more freedom.
Was that six?
MMM.
You're unemployed and a,
you're good at sneaking into comedy clubs.
I don't fucking know.
I'm out.
I'm out of it.
All right.
That's it.
That's the fucking podcast for this week.
Thank you everybody for listening.
This one really was a cluster fuck,
but I hope so.
You got something out of it as far as like complaining,
um,
you can't get your money back.
You just have to say it's unacceptable.
It's unacceptable.
Just all right.
I've already said this 10 fucking,
I can't get out of this in order this too,
as I close the windows and my room here because I curse a lot and it's hot as
fuck right now.
And I'm literally sitting here sweating like a,
I feel like I'm in a bunker right now,
you know,
and with this country's been taken over by the fucking world's been taken over
by aliens and I'm just leaving this hoping that somebody's going to survive like
Lee majors in that movie where,
uh,
he drives a race car.
I'm all right.
That's it.
That's,
that's the less feeble attempt.
I'm going to make it comedy.
And you're getting a good chuck a lot of this,
huh?
Uh,
this,
this is,
you know,
is a certain kind of comedy fan out there that just really enjoys train wrecks.
So a,
I dedicate the last 47 minutes of this podcast.
The first two minutes we're good.
Um,
and that's it.
That's the podcast for this week and now you know why it's free.
Um,
if you cannot make it out to the second show in Washington DC,
um,
I don't know what to tell you cause I'm sold out for the week,
but fear not.
I have other shows.
I'm going to be at the town hall in New York City.
That one might also,
that one's coming very close to selling out and uh,
that's going to be a great night.
It's going to be me,
Paul Versey and uh,
Joe Derosa.
Um,
New York City.
That's a huge night for me.
Manhattan,
New York City selling out of fucking theater would be unbelievable.
So,
uh,
if he got some scratch,
you want to come down and see my new wire,
please check that one out.
After that,
I'll be at the Improv in Tempe,
Arizona on November 19th 20th and the 21st after that,
we'll be it hilarides in Cleveland,
Ohio in the beginning,
a December and giggles in Seattle.
Go to Bill bar.com B u r r to get all the information and if you'd like to have
more advanced notice on my shows,
I'm just sign up for my mailing list under the city that you're from.
And a,
I will basically,
uh,
I only send emails when I'm coming to your city.
I don't spam people.
Occasionally,
if I'm on TV,
maybe I'll send you an email,
but even then it's 50,
50.
But don't feel like if you sign up that I'm just going to be going,
ah,
I'm not going to Twitter you,
you know,
every five seconds being like,
Oh God,
I just had a cheese sandwich.
What is up with cheese these days?
Is it fucking bowl?
I won't do that to you.
Okay?
So please sign up for it.
And,
uh,
that's it.
Thanks for listening to the podcast.
Thanks for all the questions.
God bless you and do something for yourself this week.
And if you get fucked by corporation,
it's unacceptable.
Remember that?
All right.
Take it easy.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].